اتهمت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه القوات
الروسيه باستهداف مدينه دينيبروبي صاروخين
من نوع اسكندر ما ادى الى تضرر عدد من
المباني السكنيه والبنيه التحتيه بينما
تعرضت مقاطعه روستوفا الروسيه الحدوديه
لقصف صاروخيا اوكراني وعلى وقع التطورات
الميدانيه تفقد الرئيس الاوكراني مواقع
للقوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه في اتجاه جبهه
باخموت بمقاطعه
حول هذه التطورات ينضم الينا من كراماتورس
كمراسله الجزيره مازن ابراهيم ومن دونكان
نور الدين ارحب بكما وابدا معك مازن
ابراهيم التطورات على الجانب الاوكراني
طبعا
في الواقع ازدهار زياره زيلنسكي لمقاطعه
وتحديدا خط المواجهه الامامي كان يحمل
دلالات متعدده ليس فقط على البعد الرمزي
ولكن ايضا بالمدلول العسكري والاستراتيجي
لكيفيه مقاربه اوكرانيا لكل هذه التطورات
التي تحصل هنا عند خط المواجهه في مقاطعه
عمليا
زار مجموعه كبيره من القرى والبلدات
المتاخمه لخط المواجهه وتحديدا في بلده
والتي تبعد بضعه كيلومترات فقط عن خط
المواجهه في مدينه باخموت والتي باتت
اليوم عنوانا لهذه المعركه التي تخوضها
القوات الاوكرانيه في شرق البلاد بحيث
تحولت بخموت الى النقطه الارتكاز الرئيسيه
فيما بات يعرف
بالهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد الذي بدا قبل
ان نحوي شهرين عمليا من هذه المنطقه اثناء
الرئيس الاوكراني على الجهود التي تقوم
بها القوات الخاصه على الاوكرانيه متحدثا
عن مجموعه من المهمات التي لا يمكن ان
الكشف عن تفاصيلها الا بعد انتهاء هذه
الحرب والانتصار فيها على حد ما قال وفق
توصيفه بطبيعه الحال وايضا عمليا هذه
الزياره الى هذه المنطقه تحديدا هي تدفع
باتجاه القول بان اوكرانيا ستدفع بكل ما
تملكه من قوات لمحاوله احداث خلق فعليا
على هذه الجبهه لان الخرق بات حاجه ماسه
بعد شهرين من انطلاق الهجوم المضاد والذي
وفق القياده الاوكرانيه اشارت الى ان كل
ما حققته حتى الان هو السيطره على ما يقرب
من 230 كم مربع على طول خط الجبهه الذي
يمتد مئات الكيلومترات وينطلق من اكثر
الشمال وصولا الى خرسون جنوبا وبالتالي
ضمن هذه الجوله فهم ان المنطق الاوكراني
العسكري اليوم هو يشدد على ضروره انت
المبادره والحصول على مكسب استراتيجي في
هذه المنطقه وتحديدا في مدينه التي كانت
قد سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه في الخامس
والعشرين من شهر مايو على مستوى ثاني كان
هنالك اليوم كلاف كلام لافت بالسياسه صدر
عن مدير مكتب زيلنسكي
حديث عن مبادره للسلام او عن تسويه لا
يمكن الا ان تراعي امرا اساسيا ينطلق من
المبادره التي طرحها للسلام والتي تقوم
على العوده الى الحدود التي اعلنت من
خلالها اوكرانيا في اغسطس
1991 حينها كانت كل تلك المناطق التي
تحتلها روسيا سواء منذ عام 2014 واعني بها
شبه جزيره الكرم او اجزاء من الدومباس
وصولا الى كل هذه المقاطعات التي تحتلها
هنا والتي تدور فيها المعركه اشار الى ان
المعركه اليوم في السياسه كما في الميدان
تتقاطع عند العوده الى حدود عام 91
وبالتالي هذا الكلام جاء ردا على كل ما
صرح بها اجهزه الاوكراني ماذا عن التطورات
على الجانب الروسي وهنا انتقل اليك نور
الدين تغير
اذا كانت اعين الاوكرانيين على يبدو ان
اعين الروس بالدرجه الاولى خلال هذه
المرحله على كوبيانس وعلى ليمان ربما هناك
استراتيجيه عسكريه تتحدث على ان احكام
السيطره بهاتين
بكوبيان في الجبهه الشماليه والجبهه
الغربيه بشكل او باخر سيدفع القوات
الروسيه الى اطباق واحكام سيطرتها على جزء
من المنطقه الشماليه والمنطقه الغربيه
وهذا ما سيفتح لها مجال بالتحرك كذلك الى
مناطق اخرى في دونيسك لا تزال تقع تحت
سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه نتحدث هنا عن
المنطقه المدينه التي لا تزال محاصره من
قبل القوات الروسيه وهناك تحصينات قويه
للقوات الاوكرانيه يبدو ان الاستراتيجيه
الان للجانب الروسي وهي محاوله تطويق هذه
المدينه في افقي السيطره عليها لكن بكل
تاكيد في المناطق الاخرى حينما يتم الحديث
ربما هناك حديث عسكري هنا في موسكو على ان
المساله هي مساله كيفيه الحفاظ على ما
يصطلح عليه عسكريا بالمناطق الرماديه ماذا
يقصد بالمناطق الرماديه اي المناطق التي
لا يمكن ان يشار اليها على انها محكمه
السيطره من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وانها
تقع في مرمى نيران القوات الروسيه الان
روسيا على مستوى ضخم تحاول ان تتواجد في
صد الدفاع الاول وهي بلده كليشيفكا هذه
البلده التي تحاول قوات الاوكرانيه التوغل
فيها من اجل فتحها مجالات للذهاب الى ضخمه
لكن يبدو ان الدفاعات الروسيه عبر استعمال
نظام المدفعيه ووحدات المدفعيه ووحدات
الطيران الحربي يبدو انها لحد الساعه لا
تزال تعرقل اي تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه في
هذه المنطقه اذا ما تقدمنا ونزلنا قليلا
الى الجنوب والمنطقه الجنوبيه
في جنوب دونيت يبدو ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تحاول بشكل ما التحرك من اتجاه الى داخل
جنوب دونيس خاصه بعدما اعلنت القوات
الاوكرانيه احكام سيطرتها على بلده
ستاراميسكي
هاته البلده التي تقول القوات الروسيه
بانها فقدت كل دفاعاتها وبان العمق الاساس
للتحرك الاساس للقوات الروسيه الان وهي
محاوله السيطره على المرتفعات ومنع اي
تقدم لهذه القوات مع الحفاظ على مواقع
القوات الروسيه في منطقه
وخاصه في منطقه رابوتينيو نور الدين غير
ومن كرامات مازن ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا لكما